yeah that thing's broke oh really but I
can show you around the rest of the
studio if you want go behind the scenes
let's do it
[Music]
what's up guys MTB HD here welcome to
the long-awaited episode 2 of this
series it started with the Casey Neistat
studio tour well over a year ago then I
was a bit of a pause and now it's back
under a new name so welcome to the BTS
and this time we're joined by a none
other than Luis Hilson Tiger the mind
behind unbox therapy to take a look
through his iconic studio space used to
make his videos the gear the team and
the philosophy behind it all so we're in
the studio the unbox therapy HQ I guess
I could say you could call it that this
is it we're looking for a little behind
the scenes
I don't figured we'd start with the
iconic desk tell us a little bit about
what we're looking at right now honestly
this thing this just happened over time
the main objective was always to get
like a push-button one power bar and
have lights camera and then I could
bring the action you know very important
part of it so these are these are just
giant they're LED lights you can adjust
the brightness but they're usually
blasting and you sat there earlier you
probably recognize this blinding he's
not a comfortable place to be in fact
and so that took a while to get used to
the idea of just ignoring the fact that
you had all this light but in the
beginning I mean you could probably
attest to the same thing we start out on
YouTube you're like experimenting a lot
you're just like maybe this will work
maybe that way and I was always in this
situation of trying to light myself and
an object all at once all the time and
so I figured out that by bouncing all
this light off of a light surface and
with a relatively light backdrop you
could kind of achieve that with a fairly
simple setup so I mean I sit right there
and there's these giant TVs on either
side that are gonna showcase what's
happening in the angles other than the
one where I'm sitting other than the
front shot having a bigger version of it
was helpful for focus and stuff because
oftentimes you know jack will be
standing over there and I'll know if he
got focused on the thing I'm talking
about or not and since everything is
happening live like we rarely redo
anything it's important that like that
we link up on that so I can look in this
giant TV and be like okay did you catch
that shot yet and once I see it then on
to the next so the video setup itself
to achieve that right now is a trio of
Canon c500 s recording into atomists 4k
recorders the main angle is with a
Tokina 11 to 16 so super wide the one
operated from the side by Jack is rockin
a sigma 72 200 and the one rigged
pointed straight down from above has a
canon 70 to 200 focus right on that
table
the lighting is super simple it's just
this trio of led softbox lights full
brightness filling in any possible
shadows and reflecting off the table to
create light around the object on Lou
and even this nice you know recognizable
gradient on the background as you've
seen and you can't forget audio there is
a shotgun microphone right in the middle
over the center camera being recorded
separately and synced all right so this
is upstairs from the other side like
behind the set where you're used to
seeing me over there and this is kind of
I mean it's a weird space now up here
this is where everything used to take
place all the desks were up here the
editing was up here there was like a
little lounge area I guess there still
is one over there but I don't know it's
kind of just makeshift products
accumulating over here on this side most
of the editing and sort of
post-production moved downstairs now
along with the new set that was recently
built so I can take it down there and
show you that all right so we're down
stairs now this is the bigger part of
the space but surprisingly we didn't
start using it up until recently
everything used to be upstairs now a lot
of it is down here including that
gigantic mess over there all those
products packed up I don't actually have
a desk right now that's kind of weird
these guys do there's a little kitchen
in this region over here of course we've
got the Papa Schadt as well if anyone
wants to test their skills and what else
I mean there's some old camera gear
monitors a couple of go-karts which is
kind of a story that goes with both of
those but I can't tell you that story
right now because it might hurt Jack's
feelings this is the editing area I
would say was the desk area is where
everybody sits we have Kirk's spot over
here Jack right there and we'll behind
that and it's where the magic happens
really it's where all the ranting and
raving turns into something that you can
watch so let's talk to these guys let's
see what their setups are about hey I'm
Kirk this is my desk
I'm rocking an old school dining room
table splashing it up with a little bit
of newness with the RGB lighting I got
the MacBook Pro that I edit from and
always some fresh fruit on the table
here I'll be editing stuff for the
YouTube channel or the social media
stuff photos videos all the things hello
my name is Jack and this is my workspace
I have my laptop here my monitor my
marshmallows my hot sauce I added here
yeah I don't have a keyboard or a mouse
I find I have gotten pretty good at just
editing right off the laptop so that
just I take that wherever I go these
guys are great they come right out of my
laptop if we want to rock out in here
and they're also plugged into this
record player over here for when I
listen to Queen what's up guys I'm will
and this is my setup pretty standard
except for this crazy wide gaming
monitor I do mostly Photoshop I do
thumbnails and stuff working on the
MacBook Pro and this is where Otis
sleeps all right so you saw most of the
main floor you saw the editing spots for
well Kirk and Jack you saw all the
various piles of gadgets over in the
corner over there course the little
kitchen and whatnot by the stairs but
the most exciting thing down here is
also the newest and it's right over here
and of course it's the new set
[Music]
so this set is again a trio of C 500s
the two side cameras with 72 200s and
the middle with a canon 11 224 one of my
favorite wide-angle lenses and the set
itself is kind of amazing there are 10
4k OLED TVs stitched together next to
each other in the back and then also a
77 inch wallpaper TV on each side and
the TVs are held up by this sort of
plywood frame that's about 15 feet tall
to fill up the whole background complete
with LEDs it's a pretty unique look
pretty modular as well and all centered
around this pair of seats and a table in
the middle so this is a look at the set
you know it kind of it goes all around
it's a it's like almost 360 in fact you
can shoot in a number of different
directions originally we thought about
doing a full 360 one but then it's like
you get weird stuff with cameras looking
at each other and whatnot it's a whole
different story but we did kind of go
overboard with the lighting the all
these LED lights in here that you see
behind the the kind of cover on the
front they can go how many different
gradients it's like a thousand different
gradients of RGB so you can set up these
incredible kind of color schemes and
then the actual important lights that
are lighting me are up above that on a
grid so the whole thing was actually
built or at least most of it was built
off-site and then brought into this unit
here and then and then basically just
assembled and set up inside of here in
fact originally there was a giant desk
in this region here a circular desk and
then I sat there and I was just like I
don't know something just felt off it
wasn't comfy enough didn't feel like a
place that I wanted to sit and talk so
we had that thing removed brought in the
couch chair situation but much like
upstairs it's often about
experimentation in this space so even
this might not be permanent it's cool
for now and it's fun to shoot somewhere
other than where I've always been which
is at that desk and that really confined
face this is big this is this is
exciting it's like I can breathe I can
chat I can talk I can be comfortable
while doing so in fact this this
particular scene this lighting setup
here reminds me of those those popsicles
you know the ones like the rocket
popsicles firecrackers yeah it actually
kind of reminds budget just sprung on me
right this moment but of course we can
change it up maybe we should change it
up right now Kirk can you throw another
scene on real quick just just Chuck a
different scene something real quick
there you go okay blue Oh actually there
was a bit of a blue there was a fade
there it kind of went to a bit more
white teal at the bottom but you can
configure everything through an app
every single light is controllable
independently of the others so you set
up these scenes for whatever you might
want it to look like and it gives you a
little bit of flexibility so that the
set doesn't doesn't stay static or
identical all the time you can switch it
up so okay number one thing I've learned
from loose studio is
I definitely now want to build a set for
myself where I can just walk in sit down
hit one button everything turns on and I
can just record like this this is the
ultimate frictionless studio just
removes any barrier of setup between
having an idea and recording it and
that's what Luz built here and multiple
versions of it anyway that's been it
thank you for watching this episode 2
hope you enjoyed and let me know what
other types of setups and BTS you want
to see in the future
until the next one catch you later peace